let's get started I'm just introducing
the next speaker it's a neat Vitaliy
talking about smooth analysis for low
ranked solutions to STP thank you all
for coming to the top this is joint work
with Tina and puja Nepali Nicola boom
all and Sadiq Jen so as the title
indicates we are interested in solving
semi-definite programs these are
problems where which to minimize a
linear function C times X subject to
linear constraints AI X equal to BI but
with the additional constraint that X
has to be positive semi-definite meaning
that X is a symmetric matrix and all its
eigenvalues are non-negative okay and it
has several applications I perhaps don't
need to stress on these to this audience
and there also exists polynomial time
solutions for solving semi different
programs and examples include ellipsoid
method interior point method
multiplicative weight update and so on
okay
even though these are polynomial time
methods they have problems
scaling to extremely large problem sizes
when you try to solve them in practice
and in order to cope up with this issue
viewer and Montero in 2003 proposed a
new approach to solving these programs
or solving these problems and they
demonstrated that these their approach
is actually empirically very good it
performs very well on a large class of
problems and they also provide a lot of
interesting they also show a lot of
interesting results about their approach
but they they do not manage to show a
general proof of correctness on general
semi-definite programs okay I'll come
back to explaining what exactly the
Burin monitor approach is in just a
minute but the basic building block that
starts out the Burin Monteiro approach
is this volta result by Bovina
and by Pataki which basically says that
for any feasible semi-definite program
with M constraints so M here stands for
the number of constraints as long as it
is feasible there exists at least
one solution whose rank is at most quite
out of em okay so the number of
constraint is M then there exists at
least one solution whose rank is only
square root of M and in several
practical applications M the number of
constraint is the same as the ambient
dimension n and this means that you
actually have solutions whose rank is
square root n so in general very uh
priori there is no reason to expect that
there can even be a solution of rank n
minus 1 but it turns out that as long as
you have only n constraints you have a
solution of rank only square root of n
ok now what are the advantages of the
flow and solutions so the first one is
that once you have the solution you only
have to use n to the 1.5 space to
actually store the solution rather than
n square so it reduces the memory
requirement and on the other hand on the
other hand whenever these SDPs
actually come up as relaxations of
combinatorially hard problems whenever
we can find lowering solutions the
rounding procedure actually has better
guarantees depending on the rank of the
solution that you find okay so these are
the two main advantages and the Burin
Monteiro approach actually gives us a
tries to find a third advantage which is
that they want to use the existence of
the flooring solutions to actually find
them faster okay to actually solve this
optimization problem faster and what is
this approach so the problem on the left
is the original semi-definite program
where we wish to minimize CX subject to
these constraints the main idea behind
this fact Buner monitor approach is to
write X as uu transpose where u is
factorized only by a n cross K matrix
okay and K is usually as I mentioned
much much smaller than N and once we
replace X to be uu transpose it has to
it basically enforces two things one is
that X is automatically positive
semi-definite because we are writing it
in the square form and the second one is
because U is a tall matrix X is
automatically a low rank matrix okay
so the modified problem that we wish to
solve is to minimize C times u u
transpose subject to AI uu transpose
well do bi okay this is the constraint
problem that the bureau monitor approach
tries to solve now this is still a
constraint problem and one of the ways
to try to solve a constraint problem is
to first turn it to an in to an
unconstrained problem and solve the
unconstrained problem and one of the
basic ways of doing this transformation
is to write the penalized version where
we have the objective which is C times
uu transpose and then we have a penalty
parameter which is mu and then we add a
quadratic penalty which is yeah uu
transpose minus bi this basically tells
us how much we are so we are not
satisfying a particular constraint and
we put a square and then new [ __ ] we
penalize give so it tells us how much to
penalize each unsatisfied constraint
okay and now we have converted this into
an unconstrained problem we can try to
solve this I should point out here that
the penalty version is not the best way
to convert a constraint problem to an
unconstrained problem and there are more
sophisticated ways of doing this but for
the purposes of this talk I just focus
on the penalized version and towards the
end of this talk I will say a bit more
about more sophisticated methods like
augmented Lagrangian and so on okay so
how do we solve this penalty problem a
penalized version of the problem so the
main challenge is that even though f
originally is convex in the X space so
the penalty version the X space is
convex it turns out that this u
transpose factorization makes this non
convex so the question is how do we
solve this non convex problem and in
general solving non convex problems is
np-hard and we cannot hope to do it but
for non convex problems we can actually
solve for what is known as stationary
points and let me introduce what
stationary points are so first-order
stationary points just those points
where the gradient is small okay and
second-order stationary points are those
where the gradient is small and a chain
is almost positive semi-definite okay
this is the second thing here we can
actually find second-order stationary
points very efficiently and there
actually has been a lot of recent work
in
making finding the second order of
stationary points very very efficiently
using just gradient descent and
first-order algorithms why don't you say
quite or equal to zero why don't you
enough why to allow it to be little bit
negative because in fact we can just
because like we cannot solve anything
exactly right so we cannot get a
gradient equal to zero but you allow it
to be a little negative you couldn't
know it because it's hard to distinguish
whether there is an extremely small
eigenvalue or not in general like I try
to methods cannot get you exactly equal
it's not a trick in my analysis so all
we really need is this and this is what
people have looked at but I guess if you
use second-order methods where you
exactly query the Hessian then you can
exactly check whether it's greater than
you transpose right okay so the point
that I want to make in the slide is that
for non convex optimization problems it
is indeed possible to find second-order
stationary points efficiently and we can
use those algorithms on this problem so
we will find a second or stationary
point of this optimization problem so
what can we say about the second-order
stationary points in a recent work Booma
at all actually show that once K is
greater than equal to the square root 2m
which is the same as the existential
result that I mentioned earlier for
almost all C so C is the objective here
so C is the objective in the semi
definite program for almost all see
every second-order stationary point is
actually a global optimum for this
optimization problem okay
there is no for every new so you pick C
at random with probability one for every
new every second-order stationary point
is a global optimum yeah yeah okay so
this statement is for exact second on
stationary points where you put epsilon
equal to zero so these are approximate
definitions of first-order and
second-order same points and this is
precisely one of the questions that we
want to us so this result basically says
that exact second-order stationary
points are exactly below Optima
but in practice you cannot find exact
second-order stationary points or
first-order stationary points so okay so
for the purposes of this talk you can
think of we're so bad see have lebesgue
measure zero the quadric means the back
okay so a bag fee will be that it has
some second-order stationary point which
is not a global optimum then the set of
all set C has lebesgue measure zero
you look at the bad see back feel bad
feel Ison n cross n space right that
also personal computation this is just
an existing shell statement there is no
computation involved here so this is
what basically says that yeah almost all
is that with the seed that does not
satisfy this property has lebesgue
measure zero okay so this leads to two
open questions so the first question is
whether there exists bad fee in this
lebesgue measure zero set for which
second-order stationary point like there
is a second-order stationary point which
is not a global optimum right if this
almost all is it really necessary or is
it just that it's a proof artifact okay
so that's the first question and the
second question is precisely the
combinational question that we want to
raise which is right in practice we
cannot find exact second-order
stationary points we can only find
approximate second-order stationary
points so does this statement also hold
for approximate versions meaning that
our approximate second-order stationary
points approximate global Optima so
these are the two questions that this
result gives rise and we answer both of
these questions affirmatively first we
show that we can construct C for which
there are bad second-order stationary
points which are actually not global
optimum so this almost all is actually
required and second for perturbed SDPs
I mean because this almost all is
required you have to add some amount of
perturbation for any given problem but
once you add some amount of perturbation
approximate second-order stationary
points are approximate global Optima
okay and I'll only be talking about this
second result and let me now try to
elaborate more on what exactly I mean by
this perturbed and approximate and so on
okay so we when we say perturbation we
basically mean it in the smooth then
alysus sense meaning that we take the
objective c and then we add a random
coefficient perturbation G so G is a
symmetrical coefficient matrix with
covariance Sigma G square and the
standard deviation is epsilon so epsilon
is this parameter and we look at the
problem which is C plus G so the
penalized program exactly the same
except that C is replaced by C plus G so
this is a new penalizing problem and the
rank that you want to get is square root
of M log 1 over Epsilon
so you are optimizing in this row rank
space and once you do this then we can
show that with high probability every
epsilon second-order stationary point is
actually an epsilon global optimum to
you is the same epsilon that I mentioned
so this epsilon second-order stationary
point means that the gradient is not
equal to Epsilon and the Asian is I mean
if you give me greater than equal to
zero then it doesn't hurt me but we
don't really need it
Chico theta to say connect the perturbed
objective to your original objective
yeah so I it would depend on like the
sinus of AI bi and so on that when you
because you are just changing the
objective by a little bit so as long as
other things have bonded you you should
be able to connect them I thought you
were going to do that you are going to
show that you know that so I mean you
could do that on top of this but like
this is what we currently show but if
you are really interested in solving the
original problem you can again try to
connect both of them we haven't done
that work
this high probability does not depend on
epsilon so the Epsilon's are already
connected here yeah yeah yeah yeah well
so the Omega
so whatever constants you have here
would come in this high probability yes
okay so it's with constant probability
for the PI thing like whatever
probability you want here that would
modify a constant that you would put in
this Omega this shown because of the
only probabilistic thing that you said
yeah okay so in terms of runtime
guarantees that we get for this problem
so we use capital Z to denote the total
number of non-zeros in the problem okay
interior point methods have only a
logarithmic dependence on one over
epsilon which is a desired accuracy and
then a polynomial dependence on all of
these other problem dependent parameters
and multiplicative weights has 1 over
epsilon squared dependence on epsilon
and does not explicitly have
dependencies on the dimension and so on
but it depends on something called the
width parameter which one has to compute
on the problem to problem basis to
evaluate the runtime complexity and
finally our result so I should mention
that this quantity is to solve the
penalized problem and you need to do
more work to as I mentioned like the
penalize version is probably not the
best way to solve the constraint problem
as such but the result that we are
giving here is only for solving the
penalized problem okay and this depends
as Z square root n plus m to the 300 to
n times Polly of you Europe
so okay so this is you could just do put
up gradient descent on the gradient yeah
you just supply accelerated gradient
descent or gradient descent you get this
guarantee yeah okay so in the remaining
part of the talk let me just briefly
present the main ideas of the proof so
there are two key steps which have
already been established in prior work
to understanding to tackling this
problem the first step the first step
prices so the first step tries to
establish that any second-order
stationary point which is rank deficient
which is not full rank is a global
optimum okay what this means is that if
you is a second-order stationary point
and if rank of you is strictly smaller
than K so let's not equal to K minus one
then U is a global optimum this was
already shown in Bureau Montero's
original paper okay and the second key
step is that forever comes from
perturbed SD piece where put up again we
add this random position perturbation
with probability 1 if K is greater than
equal to square root M then all
first-order stationary points are ranked
division so why does this suffice
basically we find a second odd
stationary point it's also a first-order
stationary point and so this is rank
deficient and if it is rank deficient we
know that it's a global optimum so
that's the main idea so as I mentioned
like all of these have been done for
exact SPS and exact fo SP so our main
contribution to basically make this all
quantitative and make sure that the
quantitative dependence is not
exponential in anything and it's
polynomial all the relevant parameters
ok ok so let me now first tell you how
to do the second part which is that all
approximate first-order stationary
points are approximately rank deficient
so if you write down the function that
we wish to optimize so it has this ugly
expression and when we write down first
order stationary point we know that the
gradient is actually small right that's
what the definition of first-order
stationary point is the most important
thing to note about the gradient is that
it can actually be written as a proud
of who matrices so the first matrix is
this complicated expression and the
second Matrix is just you which is the
thing that we are trying to optimize for
right and the most important thing to
note here is that the product of two
matrices can be small only if at least
one of them is ranked efficient if both
of them are full rank then the product
has to be nonzero n + n n cross n
so this whole thing is an n cross n
matrix this is an N cross K matrix and
if you have a product of two matrices
which is small then at least one of them
have to be ranked deficient
both of them cannot be full rank and the
product becomes small okay so then all
we need to be really establish is that
this left matrix is actually full rank
then it automatically turns out that
this right matrix is actually low rank
okay so you only have to establish that
this left matrix is actually has rank
greater than equal to n minus K okay so
now you see that this left matrix has
this Gaussian plus a bunch of other
things so for simplicity let's just
consider what the rank of a go random
Gaussian matrix sees right the smallest
singular values of Gaussian matrix
matrices have been extremely wary in the
last ten years or so
fifteen years or so and the probability
that a random Gaussian matrix is
singular is actually equal to zero so
with probability one it's not singular
and in general the n minus Hiatt
smallest singular value of G goes as AI
over square root n so if you look at the
smallest K and then take the sum of
squares of them it grows as K cube over
N okay this is the expected behavior of
the sum of squares of the smallest
singular values of a random position
matrix yeah
yeah by full rank I mean okay so you
have to do some scaling here meaning
that as long as this is nonzero and this
is nonzero the matrix is nonzero I mean
I think with the relative scale so if
you okay so the precise statement that I
want to make is that if you normalize
two matrices and then take that product
if it is small it means that one of them
has to be relatively rank deficient
[Music]
they could be orthogonal to each other
or their because one of the big they
have full rank so they cannot be
orthogonal because this spans the entire
space and the other one also spans the
entire space so they cannot be
orthogonal you shouldn't buy the entire
space I mean the full rank means that it
has rank T so if this n cross n matrix
spans the entire space that also
contains this K dimensional subspace
here so the expected behavior of the sum
of squares of the smallest K singular
values is K cube or n okay and it is
indeed actually possible to obtain large
deviation bounds for this random
quantity that it is actually smaller
than some small constant times it's
expected behavior and the failure
probability goes exponentially as minus
K square okay so this is the property
that we want to use for random Gaussian
matrices and this can actually be
extended for any arbitrary matrix plus a
coefficient matrix you want yes you want
the sample singular value squared or
just I thought you're going to do with
operation all right generally no so we
want to show that the smallest singular
values of this matrix are large which
would then meet so that's why I'm
looking at the sum of squares of the
smallest singular values but just as
policy I seek a small really small case
one yeah and you know like Spiral 10 can
be doesn't have to be positive semi
definite no I mean we are only looking
at single values so these random G does
not know it
so these picked randomly so a is fixed
and then you are picking G at random so
the randomness cannot really of
okay
so this basically says that you can
actually get the same bomb for any G
Plus for a matrix G Plus ay where a was
automatically picked and he was
independent of shows chosen after a okay
now in the current context we are
interesting bonding this G Plus this
whole quantity and the bad aspect here
is that this quantity this matrix that
we have here it depends on you
and you is an unknown for us because you
could be any second order stationary
point and a priori we don't know what
exactly these matrices can be and the
way we deal with this is to first
actually do an epsilon net over the M
dimensional space and then between this
epsilon net you look at meters is of the
form Z plus lambda I I I okay for each
of these points in epsilon net you can
actually get this concentration I do a
large deviation bump and if you do a
Union bomb and then use smoothness to
extend to the entire ball you basically
can get the result and the Union bound
over this epsilon net is precisely will
precisely give you this one over epsilon
to the M factor because you are doing
Union bound over m things and you want
this minus K square to actually cancel
this one or epsilon to the M so that's
basically where you get K spur greater
than equal to M log one okay space you
can't do it in k space because like this
matrix you like this whole matrix lies
in the subspace of subspace spanned by a
I which is actually an M dimensional
space so you can
so there are some technical issues to
carry this out actually the first thing
is that you cannot do an epsilon net or
like entire RM you can only do on a
compact like ball or something like that
and in this context what it means is
that these coefficients that you have
here you need to actually show that
there they don't go to infinity they
cannot be arbitrarily large they're all
bounded and you can actually show that
for compact SDPs
all second-order stationary points are
uniformly bounded which means that U is
actually bounded which means that this
whole quantity is again bounded and so
doing a union bound or a compact ball is
already good enough for the but for our
purposes okay this seems kind of quite
obvious that for compact SDPs meaning
that if the feasible set is compact all
second-order stationary points are also
uniformly bounded but technically it
turns out that this is one of the
challenging aspects enjoying it
okay so now let me come to the other
part which is to show that once we have
these approximately low rank
second-order stationary points they are
actually approximately global Optima the
main idea here is that because F is
convex in the original space before you
did the factorization if a matrix uu
transpose is suboptimal there exists a
descent direction because F is convex in
the original space okay and in fact we
can show that there exists a descent
direction which increases the rank by
only one and now this makes it clear why
you you being rank deficient is good
because you can actually like this
descent direction which increases the
rank by at most one also exists in this
factory space because you was rank
deficient okay similarly if you is
actually approximately rank deficient
you can actually massage the descent
direction we which rank one descent
direction who also exists in this
factory space and then construct a
descent direction which does not really
increase the rank so it exists in the
factory space whenever you you is very
suboptimal so which means you are
searching you know value and then your
direction is the sink is a singular
vector corresponding to that small
signal yeah we use that to construct it
it's not exactly that but we use it to
construct this descent direction the
descent direction has something to do
with the smallest eigen direction of U
and also the original single er
direction of U and the original descent
direction yeah so if there's a dis
induction of the original parameter
space yeah why does it it doesn't have
to be symmetric right it will be
symmetric because you you transpose is a
symmetric no but you're saying it's
convex until X domain of X yeah which
you haven't factored
yeah so a rank will descent Direction is
just oh I'm I mean it's there is a
different direction when you impose this
PhD constraint also right oh so the
descent direction always moves in this
PSD cone so it will be a symmetric
so to summarize the main point of the
main reason that we started this work
was the realization that low-rent
solutions to SDPs are very useful both
from an application and algorithmic
perspective excuse me I'm not sure I
could see that job your discussion here
holds in in exact arithmetic but if you
translate that to finite precision then
you know your statements about singular
values and going from gaussians to
calcium as a for any a and statements
about those singular values boom oh yeah
so yes I can easily give you a matrix a
where all the sink that's totally
numerically singular when you add it to
a Gaussian and here on its own so there
was arguments at finite position are not
going to do it anymore
not that I'm not here Yeah right out of
the Gaussian assign a variance so I give
you an A but how shall I just didn't
make the a highly conditioned so
regardless of what you add it up behind
your corporation America you sing a
random matrix because I'll maybe come to
the probabilistic aspect later so yeah
so the as I mentioned lower end
solutions finding low rank solutions to
semi definite program C is very
important both from an application and
from an algorithmic perspective and the
Burin modular approach tries to average
this idea and we show that this actually
does not work in the worst case meaning
that there are examples where it could
get in a get stuck in like bad places
however it does work in the smooth
analysis sense and we can get
polynomial time convergence rates for
this approach and let me just present
briefly
some open directions that I think are
very interesting so firstly while this
is the first result in giving polynomial
time guarantees for the Bureau montero
approach we believe that our results are
not right and even more importantly I
think the fact that we work with
finality method is not very satisfying
because penalty method is not really
used in practice and the algorithm that
actually used in practice is augmented
Lagrangian methods and extending this
kind of results for augmented Lagrangian
methods is very interesting we have some
preliminary results on exactly lamps but
it will be very interesting to
understand the case for in exact lms
finally in machine learning we are
usually also interested in very
specially structured problems where we
are not satisfied with finding solutions
of rank square root m but rather much
much smaller rank so extending these
approaches for specially structured
problems where you may be able to find
much smaller rank solutions might be
interesting and there is one direction
that I really like which is basically a
random matrix theory question and the
reason we were not able to solve this
very well is also the reason for like
sub optimality in our results and let me
try to explain the problem which I think
is very interesting so if we ask how
close a random vector will be to a
random subspace we are able to answer
this like this question is very well
understood because you just look at the
orthogonal space and how large how small
the vector can be in this orthogonal
space similarly if you ask how close a
random matrix can be from the set of all
rank matrices this boils down to
understanding the smallest singular
values of a random matrix this has also
been very well studied in the recent
past the question that actually arises
in our work is how close will a random
matrix be to the sum of a subspace and
the set of low rank matrices so if you
construct the set of a plus B where a
comes from a subspace and B is a low
rank matrix okay so this is the
Minkowski sum of a subspace and
flooring matrices how close can
Animatrix be to the subspace and this is
the like really key question that we try
to ask our solution depends on this
epsilon net argument which I think gives
pretty loose results and if it is
possible to get a much tighter result
for this question I think it will
automatically improve our results okay
and to me it seems like this is a very
natural question and very interesting
one as well so that's all I had to say
thank you for your epsilon net question
right yeah is the difficulty compactness
or boundedness or subspace and yeah so
if it is compact you can definitely use
epsilon net argument to get this but
when you are looking at the subspace
plus the set of low rank matrices
it's unbounded and it's on this very
field of peace and then still like I
feel it works only for compact right
maybe it gets a better dependence on
like the size of the set or something
but I would think it still works only
for compact sets
yes the thing that prevents you from
extending this to whether you're
addictive or CS yeah the more general
convex effects it will not work because
you don't have this previous result of
the spiral damages this is the square
eventually oh yeah yeah I guess my
question is why does it not extend to a
general effect subject to linear
constraints it so in our result it does
not extend because okay so what exactly
are we doing so you have this G Plus
this matrix right so if you don't have
this C then this thing can actually
change from point to point so you have
to do a Union bound or like or some some
other thing so here C plus this is still
a sub like this is still in a sub this
is a fine subspace but if C can vary
from point to point you have to account
for all the different fees that can come
from your function okay so with that
let's take this big
[Applause]